wait you would rather have hair than a
hard-on i'm i'm look i'm 45 now and i'm
like i'm married i'm calling it a day on
the hair the hair is going i still get
the hard ones but if i take too many of
the pills but up until now you would
rather have a good head of hair than a
good hair i never had problems with it
before i've been taking those pills for
about 15 years well why did you just
bring that up because because because
we're just talking about the slap no no
why did you bring up the fact that if
you take too many pills you can't i'm
just saying how hard it is to lose your
hair even as a man and it seems like the
first time we pointed a woman and go
she's bald the whole world [ __ ] gets
into this big debate over you can't say
that yet there's been every time i i
don't i have to wear hats because you
know i have to put powder in my hair and
[ __ ] on stage and people always comment
on me losing my hair it still [ __ ]
hurts but i don't slap anyone it's the
point i'm trying to make that's good
that's good well maybe now you can did
that i think i can will smith just open
the door and now you can slap
equal opportunity i'm allowed to slap
something did that bother you it
bothered me
oh very much very much i mean i as much
as we were making jokes about it that
shook me to the core because you know
as okay well i've i've been hit on stage
and you have yeah and there's there's it
was quite famous at the time but if you
is there tape of it there is type and it
does not disappoint okay
what is it just put jim jeffries punched
it's been watched millions of times jim
jeffries punched caroline yeah this
won't disappoint if you want to make an
edit point right now and bring a
computer over and watch it you'll we
don't need a computer we have a wall ah
oh god it's gonna be on the big screen
right in front of you i haven't watched
this in years but this is this is before
everyone had camera phones
this is surveillance footage right of do
you want to say anything up up leading
into it or do you like
what i will say i was still trying to
sell my cd that i was selling that's how
long ago this is 2006. i i i
the guy did not heckle i did not speak
to the guy he was upset by a joke
earlier on we don't know what joke so
there was no interaction with the
audience member he just walked up and
hit me okay the following content has
been identified as
two thousand six seven
here we go
do you want
to rewind back
just just leave it it'll happen soon
enough
[Music]
that's pushing it inwards
oh
multiple times
a feet down why oh my god
why that's audience members who are up
there the guy in the black suit security
it's not ending
are you [ __ ] kidding me
[Applause]
oh my god did that guy get arrested you
could turn it off hey he gets arrested
and where is this this is the manchester
comedy store in england okay and um
he gets arrested and then i watch the
footage and i remember i just gotten off
the i was just doing club gigs but i
just started doing small theaters and
stuff like that and my tour was selling
okay and i looked at the footage i
remember thinking i'm going to make a
lot of money out of this i'm going to
put this on the internet right away
did you make a lot of money well my two
assigned selling out and my editor
showed you really well and i i was on
the news in britain it was made the news
and like this before camera phones so
there wasn't a million angles of it
how did they record this is the camera
this is the camera that goes down to the
dressing room you know the one when
you're watching on stage just the little
one that hangs from the ceiling what
what led to that you don't know what led
to that i don't i the the the guy i said
i wouldn't press charges whatever the
guy was a young irish lad he was on a
date i know that much right okay and
allegedly the girl that he was with was
not enjoying the show it was a joke that
happened earlier on allegedly and then
once he finished his drink he thought
i'll take care of this and he he ran on
the stage and the stage has stairs
coming up to it right and a lot of
people when they watch the footage they
go where was the security the security
can only work if there's an interaction
between you and the person where they
can stop it before it happens right this
guy just you know it's like why didn't
someone jump in front of the bullet in
jfk because they didn't know it was
coming you know right and so he came up
and you can notice the first thing i say
when he walks on is oh hang on mate
you're not allowed up here
you're not allowed up here but that is
an appropriate reaction from audience
members jumping up and helping you and
being
you know getting him off if you just
fast forward a little bit you see i come
out
i wasn't having a great gig yeah go fast
forward a little bit more
uh the mc comes back out and checks that
everyone's okay
there's the mc okay yeah hit play
i come back out
hi
little thumbs up he's shaking
everybody's hand
you're a hero
oh you've got to see
that's hysterical yeah
did you win it's like you went and held
up your hand to say i i round two i was
having a pretty average gig
and
i think the next line i haven't seen
this in you the next play play i want to
see him start i want to see him start
his
he's going back to the mic let's see
what he says
[Music]
[Applause]
i appreciate you welcoming me back uh
i'm not going to be doing much more
material
uh i'm [ __ ] spent out by that [ __ ]
completely i got a [ __ ] thing on the
side of my head
we had a night on your head no no what
many of you don't know is um
that i employ that bloke for when gigs
are going badly
oh that's great
that's hysterical yes i it would look
either you were hurt i didn't charge the
guy years later i had his brother
contact me and just go i think it's
really bad that you've been promoting
this clip and all this type of stuff i
was like i could have sued your ass i
could have put it yeah did he go to jail
i mean i think he spent a night in a
drunk tank and uh that was that but i
didn't press charges and the
relationship with the date oh who knows
i'm sure they're married now with kids
and they have a wonderful meeting story
you know like like i i often think about
like will smith and joda pink and smith
like what was were they laying in bed
like you did good honey or just like ah
that went a bit rough
you know i imagine they were a bit
shaken up i i think that if they were
shaken up i think that it was a way
longer because they went to parties they
danced the night that blew my mind that
he's dancing to getting jiggy with it
holding his trophy he must have thought
that he was invincible that nothing
would happen i think he did and the son
tweeted the the next morning that's the
way we roll so i think the vibe it it
caught them a lot later
the the
grand easter i think it wasn't until
they felt the backlash afterwards from a
lot of people i think he thought he did
something well if they thought if they
thought that people couldn't joke about
them they were in for because i do a bit
on it now and i'm sure
yeah i talk about it now on stage and i
do so my question to you is because i
was going to ask you we brought up the
will smith thing i was shaken to the
core because i feel like uh
comedy as an art form has been attacked
for the last few years as far as cancel
culture
and people losing their jobs and i i've
discussed with some other people that we
had on here that that kind of opened a
door to maybe what could be violence i
was triggered by what happened to to
chris i haven't gotten hit but i you
know
knock on whatever i'm knocking on but i
i fear every day you know when when i
stand on stage in front of a bunch you
don't know who's out there
and and i feel that that's that triggers
other people's anger
and
comedy is supposed to provoke
you know not provoke violence but
provoke
[Music]